right we're gonna go in a just lay max
while eating it in and out burger
because we're living either in a
simulation that's glitching or this is
either a PSYOP weather basically like we
can do whatever we want now it doesn't
have to make sense and we're gonna
distract you because now it's becoming
this weird tabloid thing I'm like oh
Epstein's gal-pal the [__] was [__]
trafficking kids and they're calling it
like Epstein's gal-pal seen eating it in
and out but gal-pal
what eats his [__] taking 13 14
year-old kids to an island the [__] bill
Richardson that fat [__] it was a
governor New Mexico and you treating
this like it's some like fun tabloid
scandal this is the darkest [__] humanly
possible and the press is turning it
into like some tabloid fodder where was
just Lane spotted was she eating it in
and how burger did she get animal style
why is she walking around free well
nobody asking her questions she's
reading a book about the deaths of CIA
agents and a [__] in and out it's to
Ventura or Studio City or whatever
location Jaime Vernon told me where it
was I forgot Universal City yeah what
the [__] is happening there was an
article that said she was uh she was
holed up with some tech guy in
Manchester by the sea that town that's
weird - oh she's in a movie she's in
Manchester by the sea
she's in some big right if you have any
problem folks I have a Ricola because I
I think I'm coming down with something
I'm trying not to smoke I probably will
smoke before the end of the show I don't
smoke other than doing this podcast I
really do not smoke unless I do the
podcast but there's something about the
nicotine and the smoking that you know I
mean I've done good podcasts and and and
not smoke there's something about the
nicotine and the cigarette that feels it
lends itself to conversation and any of
you that listen to the show maybe that
are younger
they vape skies do not lend themselves
to conversation the way cigarettes do
because there's no pausing there's no
inhaling actually I mean I know there's
inhaling exhaling but it doesn't feel
the same way
there's no give-and-take and it just
shows that the generation coming up now
a generation that has been you know
raised primarily online a generation
full of you know adderall and anxiety
you're not you're not learning how to
really conversate in the appropriate way
you just select Ben see what he does he
just sucks on that every 30 seconds he
doesn't know how to speak to anyone
because he doesn't know it's not his
fault he doesn't know he doesn't
understand how to talk when you talk to
him he will stare off into the sky and
leave because he doesn't know this whole
generation of people has never been
taught how to communicate a big part of
learning how to communicate is to smoke
cigarettes so it was really what it is
you know I mean I don't I could
sugarcoat it um can you do without
smoking cigarettes no now I will say
this she got max well they said she's in
Manchester by the city then they track
the guy down of course the government
it's old and you are opposed to doing
this the government is no interest okay
they don't give a [__] they don't care
they don't care at all where she is you
know so the New York Post finds her uh
throwing down a double-double or
whatever at the universal [__] in and
out reading a book about the deaths of
CIA agents I mean and then there's a
review that supposedly attributed to her
I'm gonna read you guys the review you
gotta realize you gotta realize where we
are and take stock of this because it's
[__] insane and then I'm gonna tell
you after this I'll tell you why I think
I'm banned from the your mom's house
Network
um I believe I am bad I don't know that
is not a fact but I believe after today
I am banned from the your mom's house
Network I don't know I do not want to be
banned I am NOT asking to be bad I feel
is that I am bad after the events of
today I will go into why well go into
why that's my own little scandal we have
a scandal on our hands here folks we've
got a scandal on our hand it's not as
big as Epstein there's not as many
powerful people involved there are some
not nearly as powerful but we do have a
scandal
gee Maxwell gave five stars to this book
I don't have the name of the book but
you could easily find it supposedly
sales for this book shot way the [__] up
okay everybody's like what is she
reading what is what is the madam
reading what is the madam reading it's a
great way to sell your book if a child
pimp is seen reading your book many
people in this country go yup that's
what we want
she had a harem of child [__] let's
buy this book she's laying Maxwell it
gives it five stars it goes a good
friend of mine died recently under very
tragic circumstances some of us saw it
coming for quite a while but it was
still a huge shock when it finally
happened I picked up this book at the
advice of a friend and absolutely
couldn't put it down I'd read it while
walking the dog getting fast food or
even just lounging around the house it
helped me realize that my friend really
believed in something and they given
your life of the CIA NSA FBI Mossad or
other intelligence agency is truly a
higher calling and not something to
mourn a wholehearted recommendation
supposedly from G Maxwell she's
reviewing a think of this folks think of
this a woman who apart
dissipated and the horrific abuse of
children who knew damn well why it was
going on is reading a book about the
deaths of intelligence operatives of
which Jeffrey Epstein certainly was one
she probably is one
she's pretty probably foreshadowing and
she's probably not going to be around
forever